Nina's gonna freak out where's Nina come
on Nina let's come free time
[Music]
what's up believe nation happy weekend
at seven and we've got where is he
up the hey man being shine we quick
video today we got Timo is getting this
haircut this is what Timo look like
before the haircut and we just got back
for hearing that this haircut is
finished
we're going to go get team one see what
it looks like I said to make it really
short
we'll see how short they made it the
floor is lava I gotta get up I take it
up I got the camera yes a I die
let's go get emo I'm also testing out my
new what is stable Isaac lets you see
how it gives us video is new stabilizer
[Music]
okay open the door let's get the team Oh
pull pull
let's go see him oh yes there is
hey-ho look at you where to got your
hair go looking good mr. Nina is going
to be surprised look at these two guys
seamless haircut cost us $80 the
expensive haircut mr. but hopefully Nina
likes it too I'm going to be home in
about half an hour we're going to go
pick her up and she's going to freak out
[Music]
welcome home mr. yuan pets you want a
belly rub Timo wants a belly rub isn't
he a cute Timo ichima come look at his
food oh my god that's the yummiest food
ever
look at that oh yeah
host haircut celebration YUM the guys
falling asleep he was too busy playing
with the other dogs
now he got tired he's passing it he's
passing it all right
Nina's on her way we're going to pick
her up and show her mr. mo who she
thinks she's going to forget how much is
neither going to freak out on a scale of
one to ten what do you think I'm
thinking I think it's going to pretty
high Begins for the I think he's gonna
freak dick look at this guy I hope you
see I would freak out we're here waiting
for Nina demos chillin demos waiting
hello you're waiting to see Nina you're
waiting to see me and sponsor out
exciting I'm gonna freak out Nina's
gonna freak out where's Nina come on Lee
now let's come freak out
there she is Timo there she is go go
team uh go
Kojima girlfriend go go to Michael Scott
- my god you're so tiny
lovely like is the padana club as a
shirt here - dammit
oh my gosh what did you go get in here -
Wow when did you guys know what do you
think
there I go oh my god this is the haircut
Nina approved all right thank you guys
what you're watching hopefully you
enjoyed the team old haircut edition
have a great weekend tend to believe in
whatever a long way in refuses much low
[Music]
that's how I hope you
clothes like a baby yeah